frank is with us in philadelphia
hi frank welcome to the dave ramsey show
okay sure hey how you doing here uh good
man how can
dr john and i help
uh yes uh so so um i am a recent uh
college graduate i graduated about a
month ago
um congratulations i'm in 60 000 for
debt
thank you thank you uh so i graduated uh
and
but i graduated with sixty thousand
dollars in debt uh and i also
uh i'm i'm also a lucky homeowner
um uh i don't pay mortgages i don't
i just pay taxes at the end of the year
but the houses were forty seven thousand
dollars
um but um due to the corona virus i
wasn't
uh i actually lost my job so now i'm
unemployed and it's like
you know i got a sixty thousand dollars
for debt to pay off soon um and i
live in the house i can't really pay
bills i can't really do anything like
that
so what's your what's your degree in
france
uh is in uh is it needing communications
in communications
okay and you got a four-year degree from
a college in communications
yes excellent well done sir that's
awesome well done
well you're you're in a troubled market
in uh philadelphia right now with corona
shutdown
very difficult to move around in philly
much less get employed
and those kinds of things but we'll try
to come up with some ideas you hold on
through this break
all right we're talking to frank in
philadelphia he's got a paid for 45
000 house no job but just graduated
lost his job but just graduated with a
four-year degree in
communications we got to get him some
income coming in john what do you think
that's right so frank what is it that
you want to do man
did i push the button let me try this
now try it again frank there you go
sorry
what is it you want to do what do you
want to do man
uh i aim to be a vlogger from the
photographer uh
in the future that's my treat that's my
passion okay i plan on doing it in uh
near what kind of photographer
uh any kind i'm just a photographer
so why do you need a four-year degree to
be a photographer
uh uh it's not it's uh it was kind of a
decision that i made uh when i was
younger
i got back into school uh when i was 25
i'm like
i'm not a traditional student i'm 29 now
so
i got back into school when i was about
25 or 24
so so i wasn't really thinking through
but like now that i
i completed my degree it's like i'm
finding out like i i really didn't need
it to become a photographer or
videographer
you know so have you ever been paid to
take pictures
yes yes but who
as a co was there a customer or were you
working for somebody
yeah so i'm gonna ask a question we're
not working for someone
i'm gonna ask this question not to be
disrespectful but just to get an honest
assessment of where you're at are you
good at it
or is it something that you just like to
do yeah
yes i'm agreeing i'm great okay so
i've you got two two things going on
here number one
you're gonna have to join the the ranks
of millions right now
who are putting together two and three
jobs you're stringing it together you
gotta hit the streets man
and start hustling and that might be
working a shift at home depot
and then getting um driving uber at
night you got to go get a job
you got a four-year degree so i think
you can even do better than that or go
into a management position and then what
you're gonna have to start doing
is figuring out ways to market yourself
put yourself out there where you can
take pictures whether that's on
instagram or youtube or get next to some
folks
weddings or whatever the thing is in
philadelphia that will even allow you
right now to go take photos
and start getting your work out there
but just to sit at home
and wait to um be able to work
full-time as a as a photographer from
the floor up
man that's a tall ass so you got to get
some income coming in quick yeah you
need
the photography gig needs to start as a
side hustle to your main gig
and your main gig is making money to eat
that's right
and pay those that 60 grand off so that
you can be a side hustle
so on your photography business so that
you can grow it enough that you quit the
main gig that's right
and our and our friend ken coleman in
this proximity principle book here's the
thing you're going to go work let's say
home depot you'll get a job there
every person that you hear that's got a
wedding you're
you're going to be on their front door
with a with a card you're going to be
talking to them in the
aisles anybody who's got a kid who's
about to be born anybody's got
graduations you're going to be hitting
those folks up and you're going to
slowly build your circle that way
or start working for a wedding planner
setting up chairs yep
and oh by the way you're going to be
around weddings and then you might get
to take some pictures at a wedding who
knows
there will be a day when that wedding
photographer doesn't show up it's going
to be too cold or too hot or too snowy
and you're going to have your
gear ready to rock and roll and you're
going to save the day and their car
broke down and superman was there
setting up chairs
oh that's exactly right clark kent
that's exactly right
you get in proximity that's what ken
talks about so we're gonna send you a
copy of ken's book the proximity
principle but you need to get in the
proximity of people who need photography
even if you're setting up the chairs and
get in there and just butt
and bust it man and john's right the
first thing you got to do is get the
wolf away from your door because he's
howling i heard him on the phone
yeah and we got to get him away you got
to get the dadgum bills paid and get the
pressure off and the stress off of you
and that's just the primary reason for
making an income
is existence right the secondary reason
for making an income is
self-actualization and doing what we
love
and so uh we don't we don't sacrifice
existence
in order to self-actualize that doesn't
it's backwards that's not how that works
so you hang on kelly i'll pick up we'll
get you a copy of ken coleman's book
the proximity principle and get out
there and john's right and stir it up
man
stir it